you know like those those influences on
YouTube and you know they always turn
them on like is anything worse like when
something happens and you just want to
see the clip of it and then you got to
sit through that YouTuber's intro you
know like something whatever use a cow
falls down a flight of stairs and lands
on a I don't know some fat chick playing
a piano whatever I'm just spitballing
here right and that's what you want to
watch and then you click on the video
and then there's immediately some douche
with his eyebrows up going oh you
guys all could believe this one okay if
Allentown Pennsylvania they got a
staircase right now yeah yeah yeah okay
you gotta go it's just show the video
show it